the national football league had to move
around eight total games to accommodate
the fact that the broncos patriots game
needed to be postponed because there was
a new positive test that was as of
yesterday a new positive test for the
patriots yesterday a new positive test
for the titans yesterday that's sunday
as of monday the good news is this
patriots no new positive cases titans no
new positive cases and here's the thing
to keep in mind the titans
haven't been in their facility for the
last two weeks yeah they were there
briefly one day last week to have
somebody test positive
over the weekend
it doesn't fit with any type of timeline
that would apply to when they were in
the building together right same thing
with the patriots the player who tested
positive yesterday hadn't been in the
building since the prior
friday except for a brief amount of time
this friday and it's not long enough to
go through the incubation period so you
know here's the reality
guys are catching this out in the
communities yeah if you haven't paid
attention the numbers are going up and
unless and until the nfl finds a way to
keep guys from getting it in the
communities they are going to get it in
the communities and they're going to
test positive and there may be a cluster
of guys who test positive
on us on the same team who have never
given it to each other yeah they're all
getting it elsewhere but it looks like
an outbreak the titans at this point
these positives the most recent one not
part of the outbreak the patriots don't
believe they have an outbreak the only
way that they think their guy may have
gotten it would have been last monday
night in that dinky locker room in
kansas city that's the only path that
would have been plausible and logical
for the player who tested positive
saturday to have ended up catching the
virus chris yeah uh we'll see where this
goes i mean we know it's it's out there
in the community i mean yes it's it's
out there we got to worry about it just
guys getting it outside the football
facility whatever that is uh again
i'm just worried we're
running out of wiggle room already here
we are i mean i don't know how much
wiggle room we have after all these
moves we saw i can't even keep up with
all the schedule changes they made this
week i'm just gonna watch football games
when they're on i don't really know but
like i feel again for teams like buffalo
i just i don't this is where to me it's
totally unfair to those teams you know
pittsburgh went through it last week but
here's buffalo going to play on tuesday
night play a short week monday night
game now they gave him one extra day and
moved it to monday night but still a
short week and then play another short
week because they played monday night
because now that the boy will play
sunday again
and so they've had three they're gonna
have three consecutive games affected
because of one team
because of one team and again to me
that's not fair to the other teams and
that's where i'll continue to go back to
until we get in a bubble or they just
give these teams a loss and move on
they're never going to do that they're
never going to get forfeits unless there
is some sort of egregious over-the-top
deliberate violation of protocol they're
not going to give forfeits because i
think they still would have to pay the
players and they don't want to pay the
players for forfeited games that aren't
played if games aren't played they want
to cancel them with no winner and no
loser that's one of the main reasons why
there won't be forfeits but but chris
look i i just want to
nudge back yeah the bills had two extra
days to get ready for this game that is
still on for tuesday night especially
now titans have had no new positives
they don't have to do the four-day
turnaround for the chiefs now the chiefs
don't have to either the chiefs get a
little benefit here they get a little
extra time get ready for your boy blue
right but but the bills don't have to go
sunday to thursday this year they go
sunday to tuesday tuesday to monday
monday to sunday
i you you may have some folks who would
say you know what i'll take that over a
sunday to thursday turnaround yeah you
know what i can't lie i forgot they were
originally supposed to play the thursday
game
so you're right
and now i have to do the math in my head
to figure out how many games that would
be in three days as compared to this
they're still going to play three games
all right in the next 12 days
right and i don't i don't know if that
would have gone
shook and shaken down that way if they
had kept the schedule the normal way i
don't think it would have but either way
it's just tough i and again we're we're
getting to like what you've said all
along bye weeks are going away and here
we are and i just don't know where this
all goes and i'm i worry about it from
that aspect
here's what the league's trying to do
the league is trying to get 17 weeks
256 games and what happens is somebody
told me this yesterday whenever there's
a glitch in the matrix that is the nfl
schedule yeah
there's a button that
howard katz the schedule guru presses
that kicks out all the options if you
have to move this game to here
what other things must you do to make it
work right so it's not like somebody's
sitting around with a giant spreadsheet
with all the schedules cross-referencing
they've got they've built into the
hardware or the software as the case may
be the software is the thing that's in
the hardware but you didn't know who we
mean they've built in a program that
allows them to find out immediately so
you pick a game we got to move this game
what else has to happen to accommodate
and that's all premised on by weeks
being
still around once the bye weeks go away
it becomes impossible
to move games around unless you have
somebody play two games in the same week
which is never going to happen so they
are resisting
going to that 18th week as long as they
can
it's in play
it's definitely in play but they're not
going to do it until they have to do it
for a couple of reasons reason number
one
once they start doing it
you may get
some teams that they kind of exhale a
little bit and think we don't need to be
as vigilant we've got some buffer we
were we're okay hey you know what maybe
we'd like another bye week hey it's not
that bad of a thing if we have to play
an extra game at the end of the season
it'd be nice to have another week off no
no you don't want that because then what
happens is you only have limited
opportunities for that 18th week all it
takes is one team
that would have to reschedule two games
and week 18
becomes week 19. and i think you know
they don't want to even they don't want
to go there yeah and even mention week
19
until they absolutely positively have to
and they don't want to get to week 18
until they absolutely positively have to
i think they can add two more weeks to
the season
if they need to
i think it's constructed in a way that
allows it to happen and you still get
the super bowl in at some point in
february yeah but
they don't want to do that and the other
thing too is and we talked about this
last week if you tackle week on to the
end of the season
and the teams that earn the first round
buys don't play that two-week break
becomes a three-week break and i don't
know if that's good for anybody so chris
mad dog russo's idea of taking week 17
and making it week 18 and playing the
makeup games week 17 i think makes a
makes a ton of sense and uh i have a
feeling that's what they'll ultimately
do week 17 becomes week 18 make up games
week 17 assuming we can get it all done
in one week but i feel like chris it's
coming it's coming look what they had to
do yeah just to move broncos patriots
from this week to next week
it was seven total games that got
affected by that yeah i i i yes that
that's what i i do worry about i mean
yeah i don't know i don't want it to get
there because then i'm afraid that like
like to what you were saying a little
bit you know you start getting into oh
we're making extra games everything like
that i want to see the playoffs at their
best and i know we're doing the best we
can here at this point to make it all
happen but uh
we'll see we'll see hopefully the big
question was is this was this past week
the wake-up call for the rest of the
league to kind of go wait okay crap we
all got to get back to like you know
being really strict with this we all got
loose and relaxed a little went through
three weeks and we just thought okay
we're beating corona nfl's got great
protocols and it fell apart this past
week as we saw so hopefully uh this will
get players to be a little bit more
strict and everybody maybe think twice
about what they're doing
when the nfl was publishing all of the
positive numbers about the negative test
you're going to get that positive
negative right but it was positive that
there were so many negatives a coach
texted me basically will they please
shut up it's like what do you mean
you're going to make guys complacent and
it's just a jinx yeah you're setting it
because you know there's going to be an
issue at some point and that's the thing
we are getting toward cold and flu
season people are going to be indoors
more they're going to be spreading it
indoors i firmly believe based upon
everything i've heard over the past
seven months and it's hard to know what
to believe because everything seems to
conflict at some level
but the more time people are indoors
breathing the
the air that is getting recirculated
that's the greater chance of catching it
from someone outdoors it's a lot harder
to have enough of the virus to infect
you with it indoors it's a lot easier
and that's what we're moving toward and
so
look chris
and and and this is a point that we made
last night on football night in america
and i'm glad we did because nope i i
at the risk of sounding like someone who
always says nobody's ever talking about
this even though they are nobody is
talking about
the
subtext between the union and the league
yeah there's a poker there's a poker
game right going on
and they're both putting on their best
who was the guy in rounders did john
malkovich play what was his name that
ate the oreos that was his tail he
twisted the oreos yeah right teddy kgb
right right
everybody's doing their best their best
right and the nfl
does not want because here's how it
works collective bargaining the nflpa
currently
has the right to say
our guys live at home what are you
talking about
they just work for you they're not
24-hour a day employees you you you you
want them to go into a hotel for that
wait that's what we're doing now we're
changing dramatically how the employment
relationship works and you're going to
put them in a hotel for the next three
months and longer if they make it to the
playoffs well well let's start the
bidding what are what is it worth to you
to get us to agree to an unprecedented
restriction on the freedoms of these
individuals to be with their families to
go home to leave work nobody's 24-hour
day employee non-stop for three or four
months except the military and they know
what they signed up for when they signed
up for it so the union wants something
the nfl doesn't want to give him
anything the nfl is waiting for the
union to eventually realize chris oh
crap yeah
they cancelled games we're losing our
game changes
what can we do yeah what can we do right
and and and the gm told me yesterday and
i think this is a very smart point
they are going to have to lose some game
checks
before
they would say
well okay you know what the only way
this is going to work is if we go live
in a hotel for the rest of the year and
with each passing week it's less time
they'd have to spend in the hotel so
there's there's a a point there there's
a tipping point where
games get postponed and maybe can't be
made up
players lose game checks
there isn't much time left in the season
okay fine we'll go into a hotel yeah
okay all right yeah i mean you're right
it's most likely going to take that for
the players to change
you know the other the other thing i'll
say we'll see where that goes i hope it
doesn't get to that but i would hope
that the nfl right now is also making
arrangements for like the playoffs to be
that way i really would get to the
playoffs we don't we we can't be doing
this you're in the playoffs you're in a
bubble sorry we'll see when the playoffs
are over for everybody family friends
everything like that i just think that's
another thing that's got to be discussed
as we go forward so we're not you know
playing a wild card weekend and then hey
it's three weeks later welcome to
divisional weekend uh here we haven't
played football in three weeks but here
we go oh yeah i'm sure we'll see great
top end playoff type football that way
so i worry about that too we'll see
we'll see what happens
well two quick points though one
there's a belief among some coaches you
won't need to have
an agreement between the league and the
union for playoff bubble because the
teams that give a crap they're all going
to go stay in a host yeah it's just for
a few weeks let's go do it we're chasing
we're chasing a legacy here we want a
super bowl ring we'll do it and and
secondly you know
this idea that keeps getting thrown
around from time to time and i see it
all over the place just pressing pause
on the season for two weeks to figure
out what's going on
how do you keep guys in football shape
like if you have
two or three weeks between playoff
weekends two or three weeks until they
come back you because you can't just
shut down all the facilities because you
know what's going to happen tom brady
and his guys are going to show up
definitely some high school in tampa
right and there ain't going to be any
cameras around this time like there was
last week in nashville yeah that's been
my argument against that all the time it
becomes a player safety issue once again
one it's not going to stop anything as
far as the spread is concerned the
players know they're still going to be
held accountable to what they're doing
on the football field so uh yeah you
know chris sims 29 years old i'm in that
shoes hey guys yeah uh let's i'll see
you over at you know ramapo high school
later today let's go throw some balls
let's let's throw some balls let's get
some work db's you guys want to come
over here too cover get some work
one-on-ones do all that stuff so yeah of
course the player's gonna do that um so
you know i i i don't think that will do
anything delaying the season i guess is
what i'm saying yeah they just got to
figure this out on the fly and keep keep
being very strict with protocol
to summarize goal number one get all 256
games played in 17 weeks fall back
number one and 18th week they don't want
to go there until they absolutely
positively have to and i believe
there's a week 19 lingering that they
definitely don't even want to put on the
radar screen until they first have to go
to an 18th week and it feels inevitable
when you look at all the dominoes that
fell to move one game yesterday broncos
patriots by one week
it just shows you that the next one may
be the one where they just say
we gotta play it with an 18th week to
this season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports